today for our daily cancellation i will
be canceling the so-called black
national anthem now if you watch
football mainly to be
enlightened by socially conscious
symbolism and random gestures to social
justice then you were thrilled by how
the nfl season started this weekend
it had already been announced that every
stadium would have the words end racism
spray painted onto the field
if that was not enough in itself to heal
our collective wounds and bring about
global peace and prosperity
then hopefully the players wearing the
names of alleged police brutality
victims on their helmets would seal the
deal
but what if the whole population of the
world was still not
clasping hands and looking softly into
one another's eyes
after a bunch of millionaires ran around
a football field
with names like jacob blake and accused
rapist and serial abuser
and rayshard brooks a man who violently
assaulted a police officer after passing
out drunk behind the wheel of a car
uh taped to their helmets you know what
if what if even that wasn't enough well
then surely
the players kneeling or sitting or
raising their fist or dancing the
macarena or performing whatever other
random choreography
during the national anthem would do the
job
but if somehow all of those measures
still are insufficient in the struggle
to establish a new utopia
then the nfl had one more ace up its
sleeve
the black national anthem before
each week one game a song which was
penned in 1899 by james weldon johnson
it's called lift every voice and sing
now dubbed the black national anthem
uh this song was was performed teams had
various approaches to the song
but some were not shy at all about
paying more reverence to the black
national anthem
than the national national anthem my
hometown baltimore ravens i'm afraid to
say
uh mostly knelt or sat during the real
the real anthem but stood at attention
across the goal line
for lift every voice this was an odd
choice
considering what we've been told for
years about how the kneeling
is a protest against police brutality
not a protest against the anthem or the
flag
haven't we been told that if that's the
case why didn't they kneel during the
so-called
black national anthem too does their
concern for police brutality magically
dissipate as soon as the words
the land of the free and home of the
brave are sung are they less worried
about the
imaginary scourge of racist police
hunting black men
while lift every voice is playing i mean
i just don't understand if that's what
you're protesting why wouldn't you still
be doing the protest during that song if
the national anthem was officially
abolished and replaced by this other
song
would the players decide that racial
injustice is no longer a problem
do they actually think that racial
injustice is caused by the national
anthem
these are the questions that inevitably
arise and i suspect we will never be
given any sort of
coherent answer to them here's another
question
what the hell does the black national
anthem even mean
national anthems are you may have
guessed this from the name
anthems for the nation they are
supposed to be uplifting and in
spiriting songs
for about and two a whole nation of
people
until recently we always stood together
when it was played
as a symbol of our national unity this
is the point that's been entirely lost
in all the debate over the anthem
protest
standing for the anthem is actually not
primarily a show of respect for the
military
or the founding fathers or the
constitution or whatever else
but it's a sign of unity and commonality
among the people of america
it's something we do or used to do for
each other
not for the government or even the flag
and that's why it never made sense to
kneel during the anthem as a statement
against police brutality
the anthem has nothing to do with the
police except that police officers are
americans too
and and that's what we're all supposed
to be when the anthem plays
americans together what about the black
national anthem what purpose does it
serve
what country is it an anthem to there is
no black nation no black landia or
blacktopia
there is no white landia or whitetopia
either
there are countries populated mainly by
white people and
and countries populated mainly by black
people but black itself
is not a nation and neither is white
to have a national anthem to or about or
for a particular skin pigmentation
is to begin with completely nonsensical
national anthems by definition are for
everyone in the nation
a national anthem for 13 of the
population is not a national anthem at
all
it's as if the mpaa combined its g and r
movie ratings
to come up with gr general restricted if
it's for general audiences
it's not restricted if it's restricted
it's not for general audiences
in the same way if the black national
anthem is a national anthem it isn't
just for black people
if it is just for black people then it's
not a national anthem it cannot be both
it cannot be for one race and also be
national
aside from the logical problems the
whole idea of playing an anthem
four or two a certain race is morally
grotesque
it's just more segregation and division
in a time when exactly the opposite is
required
our country does not need more singling
out
of certain races more lines drawn more
attention called to our differences
there is quite enough of that already
what we need is unity
national unity under a national flag and
anthem now i don't know if we can
actually have that sort of unity now
but i do know that the kind of
segregated and racialized
pageant pageantry we saw from the nfl
this weekend certainly is not helping
matters
and something tells me it isn't supposed
to
so the black national anthem is
cancelled
but the good thing is we still have the
national anthem
it's for everybody it's not the white
national anthem it's for everyone
who's an american and that's the point
and that's why we stand it is an act of
unity
together thank you for tuning in to the
daily wire one of the fastest growing
conservative media outlets in the entire
country if you enjoyed this video
be sure to give it a like and a
subscribe to our youtube channel so you
don't miss out on any of our content